what if a giant asteroid impacted earth
tomorrow or a deadly virus rapidly
spread across the earth before we could
make a cure most of us probably wouldn't
make it but what if none of us made it
would that be it for the human species
not necessarily there is one way to
preserve the human species and that is
to move to Mars but not all of us have
to go and that's the point we just need
to send enough to sustain a population
so that if something catastrophic
happens on earth the human species
survives but right now no one wants to
live on Mars it has no food very little
water the atmosphere is too thin to
breathe and it lets in UV light at
levels so high they would kill most
organisms including humans what we
really need is for Mars to be more like
earth but that's impossible right
there's no way we could ever change the
climate of an entire planet so that it's
global temperatures actually got warmer
faster okay so we actually do know how
to make the earth warmer so why not use
the same method on Mars during the
winter on Mars there's a treasure trove
of frozen carbon dioxide at the poles so
let's find a way to get that into the
atmosphere to start a greenhouse effect
and warm the planet enough to thaw any
frozen water into streams or lakes by
increasing the co2 levels we also take
in the atmosphere and a thicker
atmosphere would block a lot of that
lethal UV light allowing certain
microorganisms to survive ideally we
would first want to send cyanobacteria
to Mars if these guys need sunlight and
felch oxygen straight into the
atmosphere
once that oxygen is in the air it could
be inhaled or combined with other oxygen
atoms to build a protective ozone layer
strengthening the atmosphere
even more and when those oxygen belching
bacteria die their biological matter
enriches the soil with nutrients for
more complex life this is not an
entirely ridiculous idea but there are a
lot of questions that still need answers
and there are scientists at NASA working
on finding those answers right now for
starters we need to know if Mars has
enough frozen carbon dioxide to generate
a greenhouse effect in the first place
there might not be enough or if there's
too much then we run the risk of making
Mars too hot then we have to figure out
how to get that frozen co2 into the
atmosphere Elon Musk had one suggestion
the planet last way is drop the nuclear
weapons over the poles your super
villain but he's since retracted that
idea NASA scientist Chris McKay thinks
we could put giant mirrors in orbit
around Mars that would focus the
sunlight onto the poles whether its
bonds mirrors or something else it's
going to take hundreds possibly
thousands of years to pull this thing
off but if we succeed we'll have better
secure the survival of the human race